[Music]
you
[Music]
have you ever asked yourself I'm pretty
sure you probably have why is she
wearing all of that who the Muslim woman
you see her she walks down the street
covered up from head to toe how many
layers of loose clothing have you
confused sworn outside
most people are wearing shorts and
t-shirts yet you find this particular
woman going against the norm and
sticking out from the rest in America
where when it's free to do say or even
wear anything why would a free woman
choose to dress this way it's a logical
question although the Muslim woman is
indeed free to make her own choices she
finds that it's faction in this way of
life she prefers to wear more rather
than less this is where she finds her
dignity her grace and her value she
values her inner self and as such would
rather not put herself on display for
others this display is solely reserved
for her husband and family members close
to her like for example the brother
father uncle Cedric her husband
particularly has earned the privilege of
seeing her beauty he earns this right by
committing to her and signing a marriage
contract that's why her splendor is not
something to be tossed around there is
an elite class of people to have the
honor of seeing
the beauty is exclusively for a few it
is not to be enjoyed by others as she
walks the street to mom she is not to be
exploited yes the Muslim woman is hidden
from most of the world oppressed and
hidden who ever are far from synonyms I
was the woman wearing this hijab or
covering working as doctors lawyers
teachers and professionals all around
the world mere covering does not prevent
a woman from being an active and
contributing member of her society in
any way that she chooses as long as it's
pleasing to the Lord had it gives others
a chance to value her spoken word her
intellect and her ideas over anything
that she may or may not be wearing the
clothes she wears does not diminish her
independence or ability to think freely
rather it is when she thinks freely and
she chooses to dress in such a fashion
choosing to imitate Mary the mother of
Jesus
rather than JLo Beyonce or the woman
from the Kardashian show when we asked
Christians why nuns dress the way that
they do they tell us these are the best
of our women devoted to God what is the
same here - so next time you see her all
covered up modestly dressed don't be
confused sad or disappointed know that
this woman is indeed beautiful inside
and out know that she is content and at
ease
moreover know that she would rather wear
this than anything else thank you my
friends remember caring and sharing so
like and share this video and support
the beam show so we can continue
educating and sharing the message of
purpose and peace peace acquired by
submission
will God Islam with the world I said I
will equal peace be with you
[Music]